all right this is sort of the last
attempt I can make there's there's
something very very wrong with YouTube
streaming right now and I don't know
what it is and I have no idea how to fix
it and this is sort of the last-ditch
effort to just try to stream from my
phone so we can do something and I
genuinely have no idea what is up with
the with the computer-based system I was
using people say now that it's working I
seem to be back alright well listen we
will we will deal with this for now I I
genuinely don't know what what else to
do but this is the this is the system
I've got and I think this is what we're
going to have to go with let's see if I
can if I can still independently confirm
that this is working I have no idea how
long this will stay and it's it's not
yeah it's not the ideal system that's
for sure but we're here so I want to
talk about the Sally Yates hearing okay
yes this is a live stream and people who
sign up for membership patreon during
the thing bill do thank-yous and all
that stuff but I do want to talk about
the Sally Yates hearing and a lot of
other stuff that's going on ok so after
much delay we finally heard from Sally
aids today Sally Yates was Attorney
General for a time under President Obama
she lasted a few days as Acting Attorney
General acting Attorney General that is
acting Attorney General under Donald
Trump Trump fired her ok that's not
really the issue the issue is we've been
waiting for Sally Eights to testify for
a while now and she finally did today on
the Trump Russia scandal and it actually
may still be going on but I disconnected
in order to come over here and do the
livestream so I believe that there was
major major news significant revelations
today from Sally Yates
testimony and I want to go through some
of it because it's very easy if you're
there for you know you're watching this
thing for hours it can start to appear
as though nothing's real
happening right and a lot happened
number one we learn from Sally Yates
that the reason she wet and had meetings
about the Trump Russia situation at the
White House was because publicly she was
hearing the Trump administration say
things that she knew to be untrue she
didn't say whether the Trump
administration was saying these things
because they were lying or because they
didn't know that the things they were
saying were untrue but needless to say
they were saying things that were untrue
so she went and had meetings related
related to Michael Flynn and what she
was aware of was the fact that Russia
knew about what was in Michael Flynn's
past that could be compromising for him
and it appeared as though at at least at
a certain point Russia knew more than
President Trump
knew about what Michael Flynn's past
helped now this could be because Trump
was lying about knowing this could be
because Michael Flynn was lying to pens
and Trump that seems more likely at this
point but long story short there was a
moment at which Sally Yates knew that
Russia held information about Michael
Flynn and proof of that information
about Michael Flynn which would have
allowed them to blackmail Michael Flynn
this is a major major revelation another
major revelation from Sally Yates is
hearing today before the Senate
committee was that a criminal
prosecution of Michael Flynn was
discussed during the second of this
series of meetings that she had at the
White House now that doesn't mean that
she went to the White House and said I
believe Michael Flynn should be
prosecuted that that's not what she said
but what she did say was that the topic
of possible criminal prosecution of
Michael Flynn did come up when she went
to the White House that second time I
believe it was two days in a row or in
very very close proximity and that again
Michael Flynn was actively compromised
with regard to
Russians that is another major aspect of
what we learned today
from Michael Flynn now our paper from
Sally Yates about Michael Flynn what
will happen tomorrow are we going to see
significant coverage of this from
corporate media probably to some degree
are we going to see significant coverage
of this from independent progressive
media you know I certainly hope so
I certainly hope so because I absolutely
share the concerns of some that there
are those on the supposed independent
left who seem to think that this is just
no issue period that there's nothing to
see here and how after the mounting lies
and again Sally aids his testimony that
this was such an issue that criminal
prosecution of Michael Flynn as a
possibility was discussed between Sally
Yates and representatives of the Trump
administration I don't know how anybody
who is who is approaching this in a
fair-minded perspective at this time
could not believe that this is a serious
issue now let me see if I can adjust my
camera to get a better angle here just
because I do want clarity this evening
as I like to say okay I think that
that's a little bit better so we've got
let me address a super chat about this
Zachary Richard sent the $2 super chat
saying thoughts on a pat only patreon or
subscriber podcast
listen Zachary I appreciate it it's
great that you love producer Pat we've
got bigger fish to fry right now than a
producer Pat patreon we have one patreon
it's patreon.com slash david pakman show
that's the place to pledge period we
will deal with situations related to
producer Pat at some future point in
time okay also James clapper so the
hearing today involved former acting
Attorney General Sally Yates
as well as former director of national
and
hodgins James clapper James clapper had
no shortage of blockbusters himself he
was asked how early were Russians being
monitored for possible attempts to
influence our election in 2016 and we
know about the investigation into Trump
Russia collusion that started in July of
2016
James clapper said today and again if
you if you watch hours of this stuff it
can all just become sort of like
background noise James clapper said
today that dating back to 2015 the FBI
was looking at specifically as it
related to voter rolls Russian attempt
to influence the 2016 election so there
was a lot here and it's really you know
people are busy I produce a show that's
my full-time thing and I still was so
busy that I couldn't watch the entire
thing I watched a couple hours of it
there was a lot there and it's it's
important not to fall for a one-line
summary of whether you know you go on
Drudge and in fact I just looked at it
let me see if I can pull it up again the
Drudge Report headline about this was
something like clapper and Yates grilled
over unmasking such a bogus headline
that was a tiny fraction of what went on
by the way those who attempted to quote
grill Yates and clapper about unmasking
sort of made fools of themselves without
naming names right now we'll get into
that tomorrow and and this is why you
can't trust headlines about multi our
hearings you've got to try to watch some
of it or read a summary of it or
whatever because there is just so much
going on here and it is it is stunning
what we learned today from Sally Yates
and we're going to learn more about it
as we continue digesting what went on
there people asking how are there
multiple streams going what's going on
with the stream if you're just joining
us i've nor i've been typically i've
been streaming with on my laptop using
my blue Yeti microphone and my I don't
know if
we'll be able to see this my
high-definition camera and for whatever
reason today there was a problem YouTube
told me the stream was working fine
about a hundred people said they could
see and hear me but otherwise there was
some kind of major issue with the stream
so I switched over to my phone as a sort
of last-ditch effort and we were able to
get that connected and for that I am
very very grateful I want to get into in
a second here the connections between
the revelations that President Obama
personally personally briefed Donald
Trump or warned Donald Trump against
hiring Michael Flynn I want to deal with
that in a second and how that relates to
the timing of the Sally Yates hearing
but I also want to send out a few
thank-yous because we did have some
really really good people sign up for
membership today and I want to say thank
you to them let me see if I can continue
to make this was a very very last minute
using my phone type of solution here and
I want to try to get the best possible
angle on on what we're doing here and
it's not working that well big thank you
to Millie Rainey and to Dave Marchand
who have just signed up a david
pakman.com slash membership also we have
new patrons coming in at patreon.com
slash david pakman show I will do live
thank-yous and shout out to everybody
who makes a contribution to the David
Pakman show you can do this either at
patreon.com slash david pakman show or
we still have I know it's easy to forget
that we have this because I don't talk
about it very often this thing called
membership we have a number of new
members who have signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership there's a
coupon code available that coupon code
is I voted 17 it gives you 40% off and I
don't care if you use the coupon code or
you don't it's there for anybody who
wants it you don't have to prove
financial need we just want as many
people financially bought into what we
are doing is possible that's how we're
sort of building community and coalition
and Lori Holcomb has
just signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership jared Monteith has also
recently signed up and Gina Hicks has
also signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership so all very very good things
and big thank yous to everybody who has
been contributing particularly in the
wake of the youtube advertiser boycott
ok president obama we have now learned
that President Obama personally warned
in then president-elect Trump against
hiring Michael Flynn initially it was
unclear the nature of the warning we
have since learned and it's been
reported by CNN that President Obama
mentioned Russia in the warning that he
gave to then president-elect Trump and
this actually brings up some pretty
interesting questions when it comes to
impeachment and there are many people
who are already talking about
impeachment I believe that it is a
little bit premature at this time but
there is a very interesting argument
that is being made now which is ok let's
take a step back for a second President
Obama personally warned Donald Trump
against hiring Michael Flynn because of
his Russia connections we had also now
learned that Michael Flynn failed to
disclose a whole bunch of stuff
including meetings with Russians that he
was an agent for Turkey etc etc and I've
started seeing a number of articles
pointing out that you may have a case
against Trump because he was told about
the conflicts of interest of Michael
Flynn and chose to ignore them now I
don't know legally whether something
like that would stand up but it doesn't
matter as long as you have a Republican
House of Representatives and Senate they
are not going to move to file articles
of impeachment against Donald Trump
unless his approval rating gets into the
low 20s and it starts to become a sort
of a liability as the case may be for
for for them in their re elections I
just don't think
you're going to see that that happened
but it's an interesting case that is
being made okay so tomorrow on the show
I'm going to dig into significantly both
the revelations that President Obama
personally warned Donald Trump against
hiring Michael Flynn the timing with
regard to the Sally Yates hearing is
very very interesting and there's just
going to be a lot to talk about tomorrow
just no shortage of big stories and the
Sally Yates hearing I know people in the
chatter saying oh it's there's nothing
new we didn't learn anything new well no
I mean you do actually learn a lot when
there's speculation for weeks and weeks
or even months and then you get an
elected official or not an elected
official in this case a key Justice
Department official in the former acting
Attorney General Sally Yates
even if she's confirming things that
were suspected there is a big difference
between media reports of something and
confirmation from someone who was
working on the inside at the time
right so I think that if you're miss
reading I think you are miss reading the
Yeats hearing if you're seeing it as
just a restatement of things that we
already knew or assumed okay I think
that it is a mistake to approach it from
that perspective big thank you to Kevin
Clemens Kevin Clemens has just signed up
for membership at david pakman.com slash
membership membership continues to be
the number one funding source for the
program particularly in the wake of the
advertiser boycott that is happening on
YouTube let me very quickly say a few
words about that I don't want to mmm
take up a lot of the stream talking
about the YouTube advertiser boycott but
on March 31st YouTube ad boycott due to
just a you know a few ads that showed up
on videos that were deliberately racist
and hateful YouTube flipped a switch and
overnight it crushed our YouTube revenue
down 99 percent and for most of April we
essentially made
nothing on YouTube and we talked about
membership as a funding replacement for
that we launched a patreon page at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
where we now have over 1500 patrons but
it's still an uphill battle and there's
there's good news and bad news as far as
the YouTube advertiser boycott okay the
good news is that ads have returned to
some degree so we used to get six ads
for every ten views on our YouTube
channel
we are now getting about four ads for
every ten videos on our YouTube channel
so that's about two-thirds of where we
were before the problem is not in the
number of ads anymore it's in the
quality of the ads and because so many
advertisers have bailed on advertising
on using politics on YouTube that each
ad that we have on our channel is only
paying about half what it used to okay
so we've got roughly 2/3 2/3 of the ads
and they each pay half as much so we're
basically at one-third the YouTube
revenue of where we used to be so
needless to say is it better than losing
99% of the revenue of course it is is
one-third of the revenue going to cut it
in terms of being able to continue
everything we're doing uninterrupted no
ok so there's basically two things we've
been doing one as we've been pushing
membership you can sign up a david
pakman.com slash membership if you don't
know what membership does number one
you're supporting the work that we do
okay so that that's just right off the
bat but we do a daily show just for our
members every single day we do extra
stories they're not on YouTube publicly
and it is it is a separate program
called the bonus show just for our paid
subscribers that's one benefit of
signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership the other thing is we do a
daily one-hour broadcast show and the
way that we upload that show to youtube
is in five to seven minute clips and we
spread those out starting at 4:30 p.m.
Eastern we spread them out for the
entire week as a member roughly at 4:00
or 4:30 p.m. Eastern Time
every weekday you get a one-hour video -
the commercial so it ends up being about
52 minutes with the entire show you can
watch the entire show at between 4:00
and 4:30 p.m. Eastern that's one of the
most popular membership benefits okay
and we've got a coupon code that will
save you 40% I don't care whether you
have real financial need to save 40
percent or not whatever level you sign
up at you're voting with your dollars
okay so david pakman.com slash
membership the coupon code is I voted 17
use it and we also have Terry lemon
Terry lemon who has just signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership ok a
number of other things that i want to
get to here uh there are a lot of people
continuing to comment in the in the chat
that we didn't learn anything new from
the Sally Yates hearings ok so there's
actually two separate ways that I want
to approach that number one I said this
before but we're having a lot of
turnover in the live stream number one
just because Sally Yates merely
confirmed suspicions reported by media
outlets doesn't mean that it's not news
the fact that someone who was directly
briefing trump administration officials
about what was going on with Michael
Flynn the fact that she has shown up and
said yes this was true that was true we
were talking about a criminal
prosecution we warned about this and
that that is major in and of itself okay
and number two this is only what is a
allowed to be said publicly I would
argue that close to half I would say of
the questions that Sally Yates was asked
specifically with regard to what is
known about Michael Flynn and Trump
Russia collusion roughly half of what
she was asked directly she said she
would not be able to answer in an open
setting like the one that she was in so
my expectation is that over time
particularly after there are non public
hearings held we are going to learn a
lot more about exactly what it is that
Sally Yates knows and I think it's a
it's a mistake to write this off as just
boring political speak
I watched it very closely and that's not
the impression that I got okay
Xion train ISM has sent a five-dollar
super chat saying sign up guys David is
essential for the movement use the 40%
off code and get busy well thank you
very much for the endorsement yeah we
have we have a number of people signing
up right now we have Jackie Smith who
has just signed up we also have Kevin
Sinfield
who has just signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership using the
coupon code I voted 17 by all means use
the coupon code this is we produce the
show every day we've got a studio we
have staff we have not insignificant
bandwidth and and file storage costs to
transfer our program in high definition
every day to 200 TV stations as well as
radio stations and membership is the
number one way that that's all funded so
yes thank you very much Zion train for
the super chat and continue to use super
chat by all means some questions in the
chat about what all of the Sally Yates
testimony stuff means for some of the
other players this includes Paul
Manafort this who I mean completely
bought and paid for by by Russian
officials Jared Kushner who failed to
disclose dozens of meetings with Russian
officials and by the way the fact that
he shares financial interests with
George Soros I covered this last week
and I don't necessarily want to get
fully back into it now how ironic is it
that Republicans for I mean certainly
years if not at this point longer than
that have been trying to tie George
Soros to just about anything they could
on the
left and it turns out that the person
that actually has shared financial
business interests with George Soros is
none other than the president a
Republican president's son-in-law Jared
Kushner with actual business deals with
George Soros but okay we'll put that
aside what does this mean for Jared
Kushner what does this mean for Carter
page we don't know yet we don't know yet
we have just heard today from Sally
Yates
about the seriousness of this
investigation into Trump Russia
collusion we've heard about the
seriousness of Michael Flynn's
involvement in everything that we now
know went on I don't yet know I mean it
we're sort of getting ahead of ourselves
here I don't yet know what it is that is
going to be implied or learned about
Jared Kushner or Carter page or Paul
Manafort or any of those others what I
can tell you is that what we heard today
publicly from Sally Yates is just I mean
a tiny tiny fraction of what Sally AIDS
knows and hopefully of what she will be
able to tell senators from this panel
behind closed doors doors in a in a
classified setting and whether will
directly find out about that you know I
don't know but certainly it's something
we're going to be watching very very
closely okay a few other things I want
to mention that we are going to be
talking about tomorrow I've addressed
the Sally Yates hearing I've talked
about you know we learned today that
President Obama personally during that
90 minute meeting that he had just a
couple of days after the November 8th
election with President then president
elect Donald Trump we've now learned
that President Obama specifically
specifically warned then president-elect
Trump against hiring Michael Flynn now
Sean Spicer popped up today as he often
does and he wrote the rode off the
entire thing as oh whoa Obama was never
a fan of Michael Flynn so it's no
surprise that he would
Trump not to hire him which is a total
distortion and it's you know what if you
were expecting to get anything
substantive from Sean Spicer then I
don't know who you've been paying
attention to in that White House press
room for the last three plus months of
trumps presidency but not a surprise
that Spicer tried to deflect this goes
well beyond personal problems and the
defense's that Spicer has been using to
try to blame Obama for the entire Flint
Fiasco have been so laughable I mean at
one point
Spicer tried to blame the entire Trump
Flinn Fiasco on President Obama Obama's
administration having renewed Michael
Flynn's security clearance this requires
a little bit of explanation but it is so
so bogus Michael Flynn obviously had a
security clearance and not as part of
the Obama administration's choosing but
merely as a sort of clerical
transactional thing he did have by the
intelligence community his security
clearance renewed that is totally
separate as a process from the vetting
that starts from zero to be declared
national so to be appointed national
security adviser for a president and
it's unrelated the fact that Flynn had
his credential renewed while President
Obama was still president and that's the
key wording it's not by Obama's
administration it's while President
Obama was still president has nothing to
do whatsoever with the fact that the
Trump administration completely blew it
when it came to vetting Flynn or they
vetted him properly and said hey nobody
will find out let's not say anything
about this so just everything that Sean
Spicer has said about this has been
totally laughable a chimpanzee sent a $2
Super chat asking about my thoughts on
blasphemy charges against Stephen Fry
you know I can't really comment on that
yet I've not I have an article
bookmarked about
a couple articles bookmarked about that
to read but I have not looked at that in
detail yet so I would not be able to
comment ok another super chat from Ryan
Couture $5 super chat when the david
pakman show be interested in an Android
app okay here's the thing about apps I I
would like for us to have an app all
right
that being said there's a couple things
that are important to me number one I
want to have as close to the same
functionality on the iPhone and Android
app that's number one and number two
every pitch I get pitched by people who
want to do an app for us basically every
week and there's always some issue like
basically what they're doing is they
would build a cookie cutter app they'll
just stick our logo on to the app and it
wouldn't have any of the functionality
that we actually want or they want some
inordinate amount of money to develop an
app for us or they don't want any money
but they want to fill the app with bogus
irrelevant ads to our audience and take
some kind of revenue share or they can
do the iPhone app but not the Android
app or they can do the Android app but
it has to be a paid app but maybe I want
the app to be free but to make it easy
to sign up for membership from within
the app so listen I would love to have
you know we used to have a website in
david pakman.com that was completely not
mobile-friendly our new website is
slightly more mobile-friendly but still
having an actual app would be a great
thing but my goal would be to develop
the iphone and android app together yeah
those are my thoughts so and and that
that's sort of where we are on that let
me say thank you to Shawn Shawn Snyder
who has just signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership people seem
to have a pretty good grasp of what
membership is I will quickly mention
that we are running a patreon fundraiser
ok patreon.com slash david pakman show
this is so much simpler than membership
okay so much simpler than membership
this is just if you want to pledge a
dollar or two or more to the show to
cover the lost YouTube ad revenue you
can do it at patreon.com slash david
pakman show we have surpassed 1,500
patrons we are targeting 2,000 patrons
when we get to 2,000 patrons I have
agreed maybe against my better judgment
to do an entire broadcast show from the
studio with my hair
uncontrolled by the product that I
normally use I posted a picture of what
that looks like to my Instagram account
a few weeks ago at David Pakman and it
was suggested by a few viewers that I
should do set some kind of target for
patreon and when we get there do an
entire show with my hair like that and
I've agreed to do it it might be a
terrible idea but it have agreed to do
it and whether or not that's something
that sounds appealing you can make a
contribution to get us one contributor
closer to that number of 2000 patrons at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
of course new patrons and members during
the stream we'll get live thank-yous as
Sean Schneider has Terry lemon and Kevin
Clements and Lorie Holcomb and so many
other people that have been signing up
and making contributions while we have
been here let me say a little bit about
the results of the French election we
did cover this today on the show and I
don't want to get insanely deep into it
but there are a number important of
important points to be made about the
French election number one marine lepen
getting crushed by a nearly two-to-one
margin my manual Makran is a rejection
of what I'm calling trumpets alt-right
ISM and I know that that's not exactly a
word but I think we all sort of have a
sense of the right-wing nationalist
ideas that are being rejected
when voters say we are not going to vote
to elect marine lepen so the good news
is that a bullet was dodged the less
good news is that in Emmanuel macron you
do have
while admittedly not a brexit line
nationalists you've got a neoliberal who
has some more progressive leaning
policies in some pretty pretty centrist
neoliberal policies and you know it's
better than the alternative but it's no
great progressive victory that's number
one but the really scary part is that
thirty four point whatever thirty four
point nine or roughly thirty five
percent support which is what marine
lepen received in the popular vote it is
still a record in france for this type
of nationalist candidate and that's
really what should scare us i mean we've
seen what's been happening we've seen
what the rhetoric has been in france
from the right-wing nationalists against
immigrants we've seen the rise of
anti-semitism in much of europe but
certainly in france and thirty five
percent this is more than one out of
three voters not you know seventy five
percent turnout so not one out of three
citizens but one out of three voters
there and who said i am going to vote
for a marine lepen and that's very very
concerning so this is a sort of
short-term how was a sort of right
approach given where where France could
be today obviously it could be a way
worse situation if marine lepen had one
longer term there are real issues that
we have to concern ourselves with not
just in France but in many of the
countries of Europe that are a part of
this broader right-wing nationalist
movement that we have been seeing in
Europe and that's a really really
disturbing thing also on tomorrow's
program I don't know if you guys watch
joy read on MSNBC I don't really watch
anything but I'm aware of joy read and
I've seen a few minutes of one of her
broadcasts in the past and she offered
all 217 Republicans from the house
who voted in favor of the second
iteration of the American healthcare act
the opportunity it was an open invite
come on the show and explain why you
voted in favor of the American
healthcare act not a single one not a
single one of those Republican voters
I've sorry Republican Congress people
who voted for the repeal of Obamacare
but via the replacement of it by the
American Health Care Act not a single
one took her up on that
and I beat it it you know they don't
even know what's in it there was not
even enough time for them to read it
although maybe there was time but but
they opted not do just a few days
certainly not enough time for a full
release and sort of public review of
that and we're going to be covering that
on the program tomorrow I already
mentioned we will be going into detail
on the Sally Yates hearing we'll be
going into detail about President Obama
personally warning Donald Trump against
hiring Michael Flynn I do want to talk
about Saudi Arabia tomorrow and I've
been following Saudi Arabia for many
many years we've been following it on
the program I've told you before that it
is an absolute atrocity that Saudi
Arabia is on the United Nations Human
Rights Committee what sense does that
make when you look at Saudi Arabia and
you see public beheadings as you know
the the execution of executions of the
death penalty in that country you see I
mean just it's endless women's rights it
is an absolute disaster in Saudi Arabia
Saudi Arabia has maybe taken like half a
baby step towards considering women
normal humans like they consider men and
there's a few small potential changes
that of course come from this monarchy
that they have from the the prince and
we're going to dig into those tomorrow
also tomorrow on the program and this is
a story I've been following for for some
time sort of generally crazy sentences
for marijuana convictions and there is a
judge who has blasted an eight
year prison sentence that was rendered
related to marijuana so we're going to
talk about that on the program tomorrow
and I have also learned it has come to
my attention that at the FDA televisions
are now tuned to Fox News by default and
it we've talked about all sorts of
different issues that are going on at
the EPA and at State Department and so
many departments at the FDA TVs now
cannot be switched off of Fox News and
you can you could believe that that is
something that we are going to be
talking about tomorrow and I also I'd
like to talk at some point about whether
not whether because I think we all sort
of perceive that the answer is now but I
want to talk about if single-payer
health care or universal health care
were to be viable in the United States
how would it happen and I think a lot of
us at this point understand that that's
not going to be happening anytime soon
when you've got a Republican White House
a Republican House of Representatives
and a Republican Senate and a newly
appointed right-wing Supreme Court
justice
we're not exactly going in the direction
of single-payer health care and that is
a really really sad thing but it's
something that I would want to talk
about on the program let me say a few
more thank yous we have live thank-yous
happening for people that sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership or become patrons at
patreon.com slash david pakman show a
number of new patreon pledges okay Lucas
Castillo has made a pledge at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
lucas to quote sean hannity you're a
great American
but I'm kidding I have no idea if you're
American there's no requirement
whatsoever
that anybody be American in order to
contribute to the David Pakman show okay
we have another pledge from Jason ver
Ville Jason ver Ville who has made
a pledge at patreon.com slash david
pakman show as well as David Leslie
David Leslie has made a pledge at
patreon.com slash David Pakman show also
new members at david pakman.com slash
membership and of course if you like you
can use the coupon code
I voted seventeen I've Oded seventeen to
get a 40% discount off of membership Tom
Mitchell Tom Mitchell has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership Ivan
Jaynes has signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership Anthony
Noori Anthony thank you for signing up
at david pakman.com slash membership
voting with their dollars it's really
pennies it's penny a day pennies a day
but a big li supportive for the program
richard LeFleur richard LeFleur has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership and of course the long list
of member benefits available for your
viewing pleasure at david pakman.com
slash membership for the two most
popular membership benefits i would say
are the bonus show every day we do the
hour broadcast show but then we do an
extra show every day that we do a show
we do an extra show just for our paid
members it's called the bonus show
that's a popular membership benefit and
also instead of waiting each day for
these four to seven minute youtube clips
to publish from our show by 4:30 p.m.
Eastern Time the entire one hour show is
available with no commercials for our
paid members and if you prefer audio vs.
video we have a separate password
protected Members Only commercial free
podcast which combines the commercial
free version of the audio show as well
as the audio version of the bonus show
all for you ok so those are all members
only benefits and along those lines a
lot of people signing up and truly I
can't tell you how much I appreciate the
people that have started contributing
to what we're doing over the last month
of the YouTube advertiser boycott we
also have a Corey Bethany who has signed
up at david pakman.com slash membership
james pyres james pyres and jessica hmm
this is a tough last name to say Jessica
well it might it actually might be been
on me sort of like Jeremy ben-ami the
guy who runs J Street
I believe it's Jessica Benham II thank
you thank you to everybody and that is
really really appreciated our goal is to
continue completely unimpacted by the
YouTube advertiser boycott and their way
we're going to do it is by continuing to
replace that lost revenue okay
that is basically all I had planned for
today we've got a great show tomorrow I
appreciate everybody who joined me
follow me on Instagram David Pakman I
apologize for the trouble starting the
stream at the beginning I will
troubleshoot on my end but I believe
that it was a YouTube issue and
hopefully next time I will have my full
a tech set up including the blue Yeti
microphone as well as the
high-definition camera but I don't know
what caused the problem I apologize glad
we were able to do the stream this way